den Weg wechseln und die Frage was
politisch folgt und was momentan
diskutiert wird das ist ja dich heute
genau ich bin der zuständig hier für die
absoluten knallharten Thesen die große
Ärger grossen und auch in der Tiefe
natürlich absolut stimmen was mich
einfach beunruhigt und ich glaube das
ist ein Problem dass wir in Deutschland
viel zu wenig beobachten Deutschland
krank an seinen Berufspolitiker ihr habt
einfach viel zu viele Berufspolitiker
hier die nicht für den Staat arbeiten
sondern vom Staat leben wir sehen da das
wunderbare selfie es für mich so typisch
dieses kuschelbild da haben sie im
Wahlkampf die Grünen und die FDP haben
sich da ewige Feindschaft geschworen
Herr Habeck hat gesagt die FDP ist unser
natürlicher Feind und der Lindner hat
großartige rhetorische Reden gehalten
tausende davon um zu sagen warum die
Grünen ganz schlimm sind man hat am
Anfang produktionsfragen nicht am
Schluss hat man schon so ein selfie
gemacht und warum was bedeutet das das
bedeutet natürlich dass diese Gruppe von
Politikern die eigentlich ganz anderer
Meinung sein müssten sind hier vereint
in diesem Boot weil jetzt geht es darum
macht zu erhoben jetzt winken die Posten
die lukrativen Renten das Prestige
natürlich auch die Kohle des Politikers
jetzt spannen sie plötzlich alle
zusammen nehmen Platz im Raumschiff und
sind dann in ihrer Abgehobenheit
Berufspolitiker und vergessen dann das
Interesse der Bevölkerung und pflegen
ihr eigenes Interesse deshalb mein
brettoyer hier in Deutschland ganz
wichtig um diese berufspolitikerkasten
entgegenzuwirken du kannst ihn ja den
Job nicht wegnehmen brauchen wir mehr
direkte Demokratie nach schweizerischem
Vorbild damit diese Herrschaften die
sich in diesen Koalitionsverhandlungen
nur allzu schnell lösen von ihren Heeren
Wahlversprechen dass die gelegentlich
daran erinnert werden wer in der
Demokratie eigentlich der Chef ist
nämlich nicht hochbezahlte
Berufspolitiker sondern die Bürgerin der
Bürger direkte Demokratie für
Deutschland Wagen in Anwendung des
unbestreitbaren Satzes von Willy Brandt
belan da ich erwarte jetzt glühende
Zustimmung oder wer auch immer etwas
dazu sagen will
als Schweizer ehrenhalber muss ich das
natürlich etwas konterkarieren Ja und
Nein ja wir haben in Deutschland
mehreren Stellen einen Demokratie
Defizit ja wir bräuchten mehr direkte
plebeszite der Meinung bin ich auch ja
es ist ein Fehler wenn 20-Jährige sagen
mein Berufswunsch ist Politiker wenn wir
also mit einer uns freuen über eine
große Verjüngung des Parlaments kann das
auch heißen dass der Anteil derer die
von ihrem ganzen Leben nur von sich als
Politiker sehen zugenommen hat es werden
eher bedenklich ich habe von einem
Politiker sein Name tut nicht zur Sache
gelesen er zittere jetzt sehr über die
Liste noch ins Parlament komme weil es
sei ja Berufspolitiker und wer nicht ins
Parlament komme stehe er vor dem Nichts
das würde ich sehr apart es gibt ja
anwendungsregelungen Ruhegelder etc das
ist in der Tat ein Problem dass wir zu
viele zu viele Berufspolitiker haben die
meinen sie könnten danach nichts mehr
bis hin vielleicht zu einem Wolfgang
Schäuble der sich noch mit 79 glaube ich
für unersetzbar hält andererseits jedoch
glaube ich dass repräsentative Wahlrecht
sollten wir nicht voreilig aufgeben es
hat auch seine moderierenden Effekte das
also Populismen rechter wie linke Art
austariert werden in der Mitte das also
nicht wenn jedes saut durchs Dorf
getrieben wird die Sau auch noch gleich
eine Wahlurne auf dem Rücken hat
sozusagen sondern dass wir diese
moderieren Effekte einer repräsentativen
Wahl haben allerdings bin ich dafür die
Listenwahl zu überdenken ich finde wir
sollten also eine stärkere Repräsentanz
vor Ort haben also sollten das
Mehrheitswahlrecht vor Ort stärken das
andere nicht ganz abschaffen aber
stärken wir hatten jetzt mehrere Fälle
da sind Politiker Knall und Fall ihren
Wahlkreisen gescheitert das heißt sie
bekamen vor Ort nicht dass man da der
Leute die sie kennen müssen um sie im
Bundestag zu vertreten und dann sind sie
kalt oder freundlich lächelnd über die
Liste wird den Besetzung allein das
parteiästepishment doch in den Bundestag
eingezogen
auch mit diesen durchstechen rein oder
diesen cdu-politiken die jetzt im Armin
Laschet in den Rücken fallen aber woher
weißt du denn dass das CDU-Politiker war
habe ich aber nicht gelesen
auch so eine berufspolitische
Abgehobenheit an den Tag gelegt mit
diesem lachen da im Flutgebiet wo er
quasi ja Teil des Raumschiffs geht an
meinem Hintern vorbei wenn da ein paar
Häuser weggeschwemmt werden das hat
natürlich die Leute verreckt und jetzt
diese Politiker die mit den Rücken
fallen und da an die Medien durchstechen
um Lasche zu destabilisieren das sind
eben auch machthungrige
damit alle
unterstehen nein was dass Sie unsere
Zuschauer verstehen was passiert ist
also es gab gestern eine
Sondierungsrunde oder vorgestern mit der
FDP und der Union oder am Ende ja
einzelne Inhalte das Bild zu lesen waren
heute gab es wieder eine Runde aus Union
und Grünen und auch da wieder gab es
Inhalte die bei BILD.de zu lesen waren
unter anderem ging es darum dass die
Grünen sich insbesondere auch nicht
wirklich überraschend beim Thema
Migration beim Thema
Steuern beim Thema
EU Finanzierung
sich nicht einig waren und das offenbar
in der grünen Partei viele davon
ausgehen dass es Richtung Ampel geht
aber was passiert denn hier hier sehen
wir doch Paul darf das nicht sagen aber
es ist doch ganz klar hier kommt aus
Unionskreisen jeden Tag oder aus
interessierten Kreisen ein Hinweis wo es
zeigt das funktioniert nicht mit Jamaika
Armin lass es bleiben das ist ja die
Botschaft die uns hier gesendet wird
sicherlich nicht von Armin Laschet
persönlich aber aus dem erweiterten
Umfeld inklusive der CSU ich will dir
kein Verdächtigen aber das würde ich mir
tatsächlich dort doch mitnehmen als und
ich würde mich wirklich fragen wie lange
tue ich mir das noch an und lass mich so
dieser voyen jeden Tag auf eine
spannende fragebilder weil wenn wir das
Thema direkte Demokratie diskutieren und
die Frage sozusagen dann am Ende auch
wie Kandidaten zustande kommen kann man
ja auch die Frage stellen ob dann
vielleicht das US-System am Ende wo es
Vorwahlen gäbe Vorwahlen bei dann der
CDU die es gegeben hätte und dann hätte
es wahrscheinlich einen anderen
Kandidaten gegeben Nena schickt weil
entweder hätte es dann Friedrich Merz
getroffen oder am Ende dann Markus Söder
wäre das besser gleich auf Norbert
Röttgen der war ja auch noch aber bei
der Basis war glaube ich die Beliebtheit
relativ klar verteilt ich hätte das
wesentlich besser gefunden was ich aber
auch mal noch zu Laschet sagen möchte es
hat ja nicht nur an dem an dem
Kandidaten gekannt es hat ja innerhalb
der Union was von Box den Laschet hau
den Laschet und zwar nicht erst ab jetzt
sondern auch schon während des ganzen
Wahlkampfes und da ist wirklich das
Problem viele Fehler gemacht muss man
sagen ja also wenn man wirklich jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich wenn man sich anschaut
und zum Beispiel den Warburg Skandal ja
ich will jetzt kommen wir wieder von
Häuschen auf Stückchen aber erstmal
nichts mit Hölzchen aufs Stöckchen soll
ich sagen nur die SPD wenn da so ein
Söder gewesen wäre hätten ihn in Warburg
Skandal jeden Tag immer wieder aufs
Parkett gebracht dann hätte Saskia Essen
sagt ja klar Olaf Scholz Kanzler werden
ja klar dann hätten alle gedacht auch
die die eher links gestimmt sind der
Wähler den will ich auf gar keinen Fall
den will ja die eigene Parteien nicht
genau das ist bei Laschet passiert
deswegen ja ich bin total für das System
Vorwahl was du gesagt hast mein anderer
Vorschlag ist aber was mich noch viel
mehr stört ist wie die Ministerposten
verschachert werden nehmen wir mal
Annalena baerbock den Direktmandat
übrigens mal wieder nicht errungen sie
könnte jetzt Außenministerin werden da
frage ich mich wirklich ich weiß sie
erklärt ja immer gerne mit ihrem
Völkerrecht und sie ist da ja ganz
bewandert mit ihrem Master an der an der
LSI die was übrigens auch eine sehr gute
Uni ist aber was ich halt sagen will ist
die Minister London School of Economics
ist natürlich grandios bilderanleiter
aus studiert aber was ich sagen will ist
die Ministerposten da wäre es mir viel
viel wichtiger dass es wie ein
fähigkeitsbogen gibt warum ein Kompetenz
ich meine diese Diskussion zeigt doch
das wunderbar jetzt diskutieren wir hier
auch über diese Posten und dieses
Geschachere und dieses spannendste wäre
wirklich
in einer Demokratie geht es doch nicht
um diese Ministerposten es geht doch
darum dass ihr Parteien kommen mit einem
auch Auftrag mit einem intellektuellen
Auftrag den Sie sich selber gegeben
haben und die der Werte in der wählen
Politiker wird sein das ist ganz kurz
zwei Politiker sitzen zusammen der eine
sagt lass uns über Politik reden was
wird aus mir ja
mal selbst gesagt
nee
selbergespräch da nicht stehen aber ich
finde es den Punkt doch noch in diesem
in diesem Sinne machen
der Wähler geht vergessen in diesen
ganzen Schach rein und auch diese
CDU-Politiker die du erwähnt hast das
sind ja eben auch macht dekadente Leute
wichtig durch die sich jetzt bei den
Medien aufspielen den Laschet vor der
unterstützt haben weil sie glaubten im
Schlafwagen bringt es sie zu seinen
lukrativen Ministerposten kaum ist der
in Schwierigkeiten demontieren
zerfleischen Sie sich selbst und da
sieht man einfach das sind Politiker die
vergessen haben und was es eigentlich
geht und darum direkte
demokratietet ehrlicherweise sollten
wenn ich euch ein bisschen provoziere
ich den ganzen Politiker stand eben
kaputt machen nein ich finde das geht
auch nicht weil das ist auch Demokratie
Verdruss den wir hier prägen durch
solche Äußerungen ich respektiere wo sie
Koppel unglaublich in seine für seine
schafzügigkeit aber ich finde da hier
gehst du zu weit es geht in der Politik
natürlich auch um das Durchsetzen von
Interessen es geht um das Durchsetzen
von Machtansprüchen und dazu braucht
Posten auch von politischen
Vorstellungen und wer das nicht will der
ist in der Politik falsch am Platz
ein Beispiel den Wahlen die du noch
begleitet hast damals Schröder und Frau
Merkel dann haben die Parteien gewisse
Ansagen gemacht zu den Steuern die beide
tiefer waren während des Wahlkampfs als
das worauf sie sich dann geeinigt haben
in den Koalitionsverhandlungen das ist
der Punkt den ich meine ich bin nicht
gegen die Post ich bin nicht gegen einen
Minister bin ich gegen Institution aber
ich sage dass das System der
repräsentativen Demokratie dazu neigen
kann dass die Politiker als
Interessengruppe abhebt aber ich bin ein
hundertprozentiger Demokrat darauf heben
wir unser
[Musik]